>> Katie: REPUBLICANS
CONTINUING TO EXPOSE THE
DISASTER PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
CREATED AT THE BORDER, MEETING
WITH TEXAS LEADERS AT THE
EPICENTER OF THE CRISIS, TO STOP
THE SURGE OF MIGRANTS AND DRUGS
FLOODING INTO THE COUNTRY, THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AND
GOVERNOR ABBOTT GOING AFTER
PRESIDENT BIDEN DURING THEIR
VISIT TO THE BORDER EARLIER,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LOOK AT THIS BORDER, LOOK
WHAT YOU SEE, YOU SEE AN
UNFINISHED BORDER, THIS IS
BIDEN'S FAULT, PRESIDENT BIDEN
NEEDS TO STOP RIGHT THERE AND
FINISH BUILDING THE BORDER WALL,
IT'S ALMOST 1000%.
>> MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE COMING
IN BUT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
DRUGS, HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
IF HE WOULD HAVE JUST DONE
NOTHING WE WOULD HAVE NOW THE
STRONGEST BORDER WE'VE EVER HAD,
IT WAS GETTING BETTER AND BETTER
BECAUSE IT WAS ALL TAKING IN.
>> Katie: THE FORMER PRESIDENT
AND GOVERNOR ABBOTT SITTING DOWN
THE SEAN HANNITY FOR TOWN HALL
TONIGHT, BIDEN DOES HAPPEN TO GO
TO THE BEACH QUITE OFTEN WHEN HE
GOES TO DELAWARE, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS EITHER
INCOMPETENT OR TOTALLY FINE WITH
WHAT'S HAPPENING BECAUSE THEY
AREN'T TRYING TO STOP IT.
>> Jesse: IT'S DESIGNED, THEY
ARE SADISTIC, CHILD TRAFFICKING,
SEX TRAFFICKING, THESE OVERDOSE
NUMBERS NOW, TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF AMERICANS AND THE 2 POUNDS OF
FENTANYL CAN KILL HAVE A MILLION
AMERICANS, TO GO POUNDS, RECORD
AMOUNTS OF FENTANYL AND MESS
COMING THROUGH, SAYING KIDS AND
CAGES ARE SUICIDAL AND
CONFISCATING ANY SHARP OBJECTS
BECAUSE THEY ARE TRYING TO OFF
THEMSELVES, THEY ARE HORRIBLY
DEPRESSED AND HAVING PANIC
ATTACKS, TRYING TO ESCAPE FROM
THE CAGES JOE IS KEEPING THEM
IN, DONALD TRUMP IS DOWN THERE,
BOOTS ON THE GROUND TRYING TO
HIGHLIGHT WHAT'S GOING ON, I
DON'T THINK THE MEDIA IS GOING
TO USE THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HIGHLIGHT THE BROKEN BORDER,
THEY ARE GOING TO SPIN IT, MAKE
IT PERSONAL, MAKE IT ABOUT TRUMP
AND LEAD WITH COSBY OR SOMETHING
ELSE AND THAT'S A SHAME BECAUSE
AMERICANS ARE DYING.
>> Greg: WE DID BUT THEY WON'T
EVEN COVER THIS END WE COVER IT
ALL THE TIME.
>> Katie: WE ARE TOLD THAT CNN
IS CURRENTLY AT THE BORDER.
THE TWO THE EVENING NEWS.
>> Katie: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
CONTRAST BETWEEN THE CURRENT
VICE PRESIDENT WHO DECIDED TO GO
EL PASO AND THE FORMER PRESIDENT
VISITING TODAY, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION POLICIES SO WHAT
ABOUT THAT CONTRAST?
IT'S CLEARLY AN ISSUE THAT
AMERICANS CARE ABOUT.
>> Harold: I THINK DEMOCRATS
TRY TO WORK A DEAL HERE AND THE
DEAL OUGHT TO BE, FINISH THE
WALL, FIGURE OUT HOW WE ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE UNDERLYING CAUSES
AND ROOT CAUSES, A POINT OF
LIKENESS AND LEVITY HERE, IF
VISITING THE BORDER WOULD SOLVE
OUR IMMIGRATION CHALLENGES, THIS
PROBLEM WOULD HAVE BEEN SOLVED A
LONG TIME AGO, LINDSEY GRAHAM
AND MARCO RUBIO, TED CRUZ AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND OTHER
PRESIDENTS, I GET THE POLITICS
OF IT BUT IF WE ONLY WANT TO
PLAY THE POLITICS EVERY TWO
YEARS THIS IS WHAT WE SHOULD
KEEP DOING.
IF WE WANT TO TRY TO SOLVE THIS,
THE MESSAGING, THE BORDER,
DEMOCRATS OUGHT TO AGREE TO
BUILD OUT THIS WALL, REPUBLICANS
ARE AGREEING TO SOME ROOT CAUSES
AND FIGURING OUT WHAT WE DO WITH
A NUMBER OF UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE
HERE IN AMERICA WHO WILL PAY
THEIR TAXES AND GET ON A PATH
THE RIGHT WAY.
THAT OUGHT TO BE THE PLAN.
>> Katie: THE CURRENT
VICE PRESIDENT'S JOB IS TO DO
THOSE THREE THINGS AND INSTEAD
OF SEEING IT FIRSTHAND SHE WENT
SOMEWHERE AND DIDN'T GET THE
KIND OF BREATHING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
GOVERNOR ABBOTT GAVE TODAY.
>> Dana: BY THE END OF JULY IF
SHE HASN'T PRESENTED SOME KIND
OF POLICY RECOMMENDATION TO THE
PRESIDENT YOU HAVE TO SAY IT WAS
A FAILED MISSION.
ALREADY IT LOOKS LIKE BUT MAYBE
UNTIL THE END OF JULY, ARE YOU
GOING TO BE ABLE TO COME BACK
AND SAY YOU'VE DONE SOMETHING?
THAT -- SHE WANTS TO DEAL WITH
THE ROOT CAUSES AND ROOT CAUSES
TAKE A LONG TIME TO DEAL IS,
ACTUALLY.
A COUPLE THINGS CAN MITIGATE THE
PROBLEM, JUST A MENTION TO
CHILDREN, THE MEXICAN
IMMIGRATION OFFICIALS FOUND A
2-YEAR-OLD BOY ON THE SIDE OF
THE ROAD.
HE HAD BEEN ABANDONED,
SURROUNDED BY TRASH, TWO YEARS
OLD AND THERE HE IS RIGHT THERE.
SO THERE'S ROOT CAUSES, YOU CAN
DEAL WITH THE ECONOMICS OF LAW
AND ORDER IN GUATEMALA, FINE,
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THEY CAN'T
SUPPORT OUR THINGS ARE ALREADY
THERE TO HELP THEM, REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSWOMAN EVETTE HAROLD
FORCED A VOTE ON THE HOUSE
FLOOR, PLEASE DO NOT REMOVE
TITLE 42 WHICH IT BASICALLY IS
THE PUBLIC HEALTH RULE THAT SAID
YOU CAN TURN PEOPLE BACK AWAY
FROM THE BORDER.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
ABOUT TO REPEAL THAT, WHY WOULD
YOU DO THAT?
IT'S GIVING YOU A TOOL TO HELP
YOU DEAL WITH THE REAL EMERGENCY
BUT THE DEMOCRATS BLOCKED IT SO
I THINK UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
KIND OF IN THIS VORTEX, THE
MEDIA WILL COVER THE OTHER TRUMP
STORY OR THE SPLIT SCREEN, AND
HIS ORGANIZATION.
GREG, TODAY AND THIS QUESTION,
WHY WOULD THEY CONTINUE TO MAKE
THIS WORSE?
>> Greg: THAT CHILD WILL BE ON
THE COVER OF EVERY MAGAZINE
INCLUDING "BETTER HOMES
AND GARDENS."
CNN ANCHOR IS SHAKING WITH RAGE,
CRYING, SO WHY ARE THEY MAKING
IT WORSE?
MY THEORY IS EVIL BY EXTENSION,
IT'S THE CURSE OF TODAY'S
THINKING, EVERYTHING LINKED TO
X.
THE PROBLEM WITH TRUMP'S HE'S
HAD A LOT OF REALLY GREAT IDEAS
BUT THEY ARE EVIL BY EXTENSION
BECAUSE THEY COME FROM HIM.
THE WALL IS THE PERFECT EXAMPLE,
JUST THE THOUGHT OF IT WORKED.
EVERYBODY UNDERSTOOD IT, BUT
IT'S EVIL.
THAT'S HIS IDEA, WHY IS IT THAT
ALL THE INSTITUTIONS ARE GETTING
SOFTER, LIKE, TALK ABOUT THE
BORDER OR ANYWHERE.
IT'S BECAUSE TRUMP'S POSITIONS
WERE ALWAYS THE TOUGH POSITIONS.
VERY TOUGH, NO-NONSENSE, LINE
ORDER, TOUGH ON CRIME.
YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENS, THEY HAVE
TO BE ANTI-X.
WHAT HAPPENS, FAUCI IN THE MEDIA
SAY NO, NO, NO.
IT IS OFTEN JUST A LOST CAUSE,
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
ISSUER THE IDEA, WANT TO STAKE
OUT A POSITION, THE OTHER SIDE
HAS TO TAKE THE OTHER SIDE SO
EVEN IF ALL OF A SUDDEN TRUMP
SAID I AM TO OPEN BORDERS, CNN
AND THE MEDIA WOULD BE FOR T